I get occasionally called by somebody
from inside and what I think they're
doing first of all one we may be faking
a UFO situation for reasons that I don't
understand if we are faking a UFO
situation do you think that there's
technology that's available to people in
the United States that is beyond our
current understanding of what's possible
ninety percent no it's very hard to
imagine physicists continuing to work on
nothing we're talking about wasted lives
people are going to be very weird when
they realize that they blew their entire
career I think we are playing paintball
rather than going to war and we're
giving prizes for generals who command
the best paintball Army I want to do the
thing that isn't paintball they're not
talking about things that can extend
Einstein people have forgotten how
terrifying important wonderful
jaw-dropping and awesome physics is
because it hasn't done anything that
completely screws your mind